okay we're visiting with you here in LA
and part of the reason that you're out
here is because of tug and we've heard a
lot of great things about tug what's
your experience been but the service tug
has been it's like a new wave of you
know distribution for independent
filmmakers and actually Studios use it
as well but it's something that's really
something that has a filmmaker as an
independent filmmaker we can access the
public directly almost like a
crowdfunding type of way where they can
just bring anything any film they want
to the local theater in a multiplex
instead of you know in the past years we
were trying to do something where it's
an alternative venue as a bar it was
kind of like a amazing space but this is
like a legitimate theater where they
love going to so it's something that is
something where we can actually share on
the revenue and bring the film our film
to whoever wants to see it unraveled
around the country so it's something
revolutionary anything for us can you
take us through the process of actually
signing up and then how did you actually
post the film online and what was the
response right I had an introduction
from a friend who had a film in there as
well so right now I think it's kind of
the network is I don't know what the way
it's kind of bum my invitation right
okay so but if they're very open to
independent film it's not they don't
want to just have a library of the
studio films they actually I think
probably make more money doing studio
films because the grassroots marketing
and the filmmaker themselves are the
ones bringing their screenings around
around the country so it's something
they actually very open and embracing
towards to that so it's something where
someone introduced me they took a look
at the film and the faculties it had
gotten and then
they said was added and I was off to the
races and so people sort of bid on on
the ticket or they put in their own
ticket and are they charged right away
so this is where it's just a pre selling
a ticket so it's just the face value of
whatever the admission price is going to
be and tug will help you set it with a
theater and then you basically just pre
by how many you want the only thing is
you have to book a minimum amount of
seats for that screening to actually
happen and that's the kind of the
Kickstarter crowdfunding aspect where
you know it's about 40 to 50 seats
usually maybe 100 seats on a bigger
Metropolitan theater where you have to
sell those seats to make that screening
happen and they usually give you about a
month to make it happen before the
screening
are you ever out any money if you don't
make your quota no it's just that the
screening doesn't have this screen does
that's it yeah and then the people that
basically pre reserved their tickets
aren't charged until the screening is
locked in an official otherwise it just
puts a hold on their credit card and are
you planning any other tug screenings
around the country I know there's a lot
of demands in film yeah yeah we are
bringing how do you write a Joe sermons
on ideally around about ten to twelve
cities in the spring where we will try
to cross promote it when we actually
have a digital release with the film
school and are you touring with the
actors as well as so you could do Q days
yeah ideally you know on the East Coast
it'll be more the east coast-based
people and then on the west coast
because kristina Rose is out in LA now
social kind of do the West Coast leg and
my composure ken Lambeau loves to go to
everyone so I think he'll try to make it
to all and it's just fun because it's
the added attraction instead of just
screening if you can show up and make it
an event like a one and only event where
you're going to be there will either
give away soundtracks or if you're gonna
have posters or something else then you
can really pack those little seeds any
quick tips to fellow filmmakers on being
part of a Q&A I know I've seen some
people really love it and the attention
is great and then others who get really
really shy even though they're used to
speaking in public any tips you can do
I'm not that good that I'm not good at
them so I don't know I it's you just
have to be on as honest as possible and
surround yourself with the actors so
they can take most of the questions that
yes you know but it's it's but it's fun
to me though because you're always
getting something different and that's
something where I always have like stock
answers that I'll use and I'm tired of
using them most of the time so it's fun
when you get those audience members who
have something so off the wall that you
can just answer it you know and it's fun
and that's I guess the keys to have fun
as you're entering them
you